I was you know Seth and Evan and Greg
Mottola you know they really were so
open to whatever I wanted to do and I
wanted to give him glasses because when
I grew up in Tulsa Oklahoma there was a
cop that would bust us sometimes and he
wore glasses and it just kind of damask
you laid it like we just we couldn't be
we were never afraid of him because he
had glasses on and then this idea that
he becomes you know that he and McLovin
are best friends if this kid McLovin is
his best friend and i thought that was
funny and i remember what helped me with
that character was Greg Mottola gave me
a note there's a scene in the movie and
we shot it early where we're Slater
busts into a house party and McLovin is
having sex with a girl and he you know I
played it in a way for comedy I played
it big and over-the-top and I was
jealous but I played it for comedy
meaning like what are you doing after a
couple of takes of that Greg came over
to mean he went this guy's your best
friend and he just ran out on you and I
went okay got it and then that's to take
that's in the movie where I'm like what
is it why'd you do that like why why
would you run off like that man like
why'd you do that and it just became
infinitely funny I remember I started
doing that and the boom started shaking
because the boom guy started laughs
ain't like everyone started laughing cuz
it was like just so real and it taught
that taught me a big lesson
[Music]
Dave and hot rod is based on a guy I
went to high school with and the story
and that about him being on acid and a
piece of metal flying into his eye that
that happened to my friend I think he
took magic mushrooms and he went into
his his courage and started soldering
stuff and a piece of metal flew into his
eye and he called us and was like hey
Can Has take me to the emergency room
apparently someone told me he saw the
movie and then Wow that was nuts
you know how Seymour the piece of metal
the guy's tripping balls on the piece of
metal flies into his eye you know that
happen to me once it's like yeah it's
based on you dummy
I'm making him sound like he's not smart
he's actually brilliant but he's just
like such an Oklahoma dude and now he's
like a professor I don't think he wants
his students to know that that's based
on
I auditioned for Tropic Thunder and
there's a an executive who works at
Paramount who I could do a good
impression of and I did the reading a
couple of times then I told Ben Stiller
I'm like you know I can do an impression
of this guy and he said what's that I
was like I just want you all to know
that we're having such a good time here
and I remember he said this executive is
unset and he goes do you know why they
make the sandwich was so fresh and then
he turned to the guy who made the
sandwich is why the sandwich is so fresh
and the guy kind of awkwardly was like I
made them this morning because because
he made them this morning and I did that
in front of Ben and he laughed really
hard and I went oh cool all right well
and I didn't read the script I learned
what I just did I did that and he knew
the guy and he started laughing and then
a couple days later my agent called me
is like yeah you got the part and then
we had the table read for that table
ready for Tropic Thunder was insane
it was like that whole group and then
Tom Cruise walked in and Tom Cruise
because I had a lot of scenes with him
he sat down next to me and he was
awesome you know what when he had all
the makeup on and stuff it was really
easy to chat with him because you forgot
it was Tom Cruise and he was just going
so crazy and over-the-top in it that it
didn't feel like Tom Cruise but then we
would sit in between Tessa you know
setups and I mean he was so generous I
mean I was asked I go you know risky
business is such a great movie man when
he goes oh thank you thank you yeah we
did that it was you know and he would
really give you really great stories
that had great advice in them in the
thriller les grossman thing and I would
just be chatting with them and he'd be
fine and then it wasn't until the
premiere of the movie that again I saw
him without the makeup on he was like
hey man and okay Tom Cruise just yeah
he's just you know he's giant movie star
that's right yeah I'm in the second Star
Trek movie I'm a voice of a ship
JJ called and said hey man can you do
you want to do a voice for a ship and
the new Star Wars Star Trek and I went
sure and he goes and you do it like
today Michael I'm in Las Vegas he's like
let me get into this and then it just
got a call going a car's picking you up
to take you to this little recording
studio in Vegas and I went in and I did
it like three times and then left and
then a bunch of SNL people were watching
the movie and they all went ha ha
there's bill I wouldn't have noticed me
but really now there's no like that's
the weird thing you do these things and
you do that they're so fast I don't
I've watched things that I've done
voices and I fully forgot I was in it I
have three small children and we'll
watch movies and then suddenly my voice
pops up in it like Ice Age 3 or
something I'm a gazelle and it's like
hey I don't like when the hell did I do
this they think it's embarrassing they
think it's terrible they don't like it
they're like oh it's embarrassing but I
mean I would be embarrassed that's the
thing I always say it's like if I was
watching Star Wars and my dad showed up
on the Millennium Falcon I'd be like
just blows hey guys how's it going hey
what's happening you guys wanna go hey
Billy would love if you guys went to
warp speed or wherever you call it oh my
god
Jesus yeah it's embarrassing
[Music]
yeah the bb-8 voice is very that's like
JJ Abrams being just a nice guy and
being like I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
like a fanboy dream of having your
credits in a Star Wars movie I just know
I courted sounds and it didn't really
work like I was going I was doing all
these and I would watch the movie so I
got to watch the Star Wars movie seven
months before it came out and a little
boost watching it on a little monitor
and I would just do ADR for any time
bb-8 came up and I would just do like
these things and it didn't seem right
and I was like well maybe Gary Rydstrom
was like when we can manipulate it and
do stuff with it it wasn't working so
well I got to see the movie early that's
cool and then in November the movie came
out in December November JJ called me
and said we figured it out it's this
talk box like the Peter Frampton the
Peter Frampton like you know like and
then and he hooked it to this app on his
iPad so what bb-8 is is me in the first
movie I don't know what they did in the
other movies I didn't work on the other
movies but it's just me with this this
talkbox going like and I'm just doing
that and JJ and the guys were
manipulating it as I'm doing it and it
took maybe an hour and I get asked about
it and now I assign pictures of bb-8
everywhere it's like this big thing and
I did it in all of an hour
the great Gardens episode that was Seth
Meyers idea and he said what if you guys
did great Gardens and I remember to be
honest Fred and I were a bit we didn't
want to do it because it was this
dressing in drag and we were like you
know there's a lot of funny women out
there and I just dressing in drag feels
kind of like another time I just I just
don't like it like I love Monty Python
that love gets the hall but anytime
they're dressed in drag it always feels
like a little out of step it just
doesn't hold up or something and so we
didn't want to do it and then the irony
was he just persisted and was like you
guys are the only two people in the show
like no one's gonna call you out on this
like just go do it and so we did it and
no one gave you shirt it's the one that
everyone knows so clearly Seth was right
[Music]
very very different than anything I've
ever done he's he's kind of a it's not
necessarily a cypher but you know he's
kind of a new soul you know he doesn't
he's kind of experienced in LA and all
these people and and he's trying to find
a community and he's trying to get in
touch with like what's wrong with him
cuz he knows he's murdered all these
people and he knows that's that's wrong
but he can't you know he can't figure it
out and he can't really even like find a
way to talk about it
he can't even verbalize it you know this
idea that he works in the shadows and
lives in the shadows but he wants to be
in the spotlight there's a funny
conflict there so we decided to pitch it
to HBO and again we said we want to play
it very straight we don't want it to be
it's not broad or anything and HBO that
people that HBO had seen me in a movie
called skeleton twins and they said oh
we really like skeleton twins and we
liked your acting in that so yeah
I'll just go to table reads for dramas
because no one thought of me in that way
and I wanted to do that kind of work and
so I did a table read for this drama and
the casting director AV Kaufman saw me
and really liked me so when she was
casting skeleton twins you know they
were looking at more kind of dramatic
actors and she said you know who's
really good is you know would be really
good is me and and so I had this meeting
with him and he was like I he the guy
just doesn't you know you do Stefan you
know and all that and no like you know I
could you know work with you on the
character and I and I know and the idea
was that you know him being gays and
he's out and proud has nothing to do
he's depressed and I related to the idea
of like no one's told you you're good at
something you know you move out to LA
you get away from your hometown and
there was a part of that Milo character
that I could have been that if just like
one or two things went wrong I would
have been right back home and pissed off
and you know and I related to that those
feelings and so I think we saw the
character the same way which is like you
know play him out and play you know you
can be flamboyant and not there always
seem to be a thing of like you know
Craig and I talked about like don't
people don't want to play them too
flamboyant especially straight actors
because I don't want to seem like
they're doing a caricature or whatever
and I get that and I but you know Craig
and I were saying yeah we know plenty of
gay friends who were out and very
flamboyant and like just play it that
way
and the fact that he gave me so much he
had so much confidence in me meant a lot
and then get to work with Kristen in
that way it was fantastic because it
just was so we have eight we had eight
years of experience together so there
was no acting it was just we were just
reacting off each other and
and it was a blast while the one
everyone loved was Stefan that was the
one everyone talked about the most which
was a blast that was always fun to do
that was based on a barista and Chelsea
who actually turned out to be friends
with kate mckinnon after the fact which
was funny he didn't talk like that early
dressed like that it was just this
attitude he had and then John Mulaney
had a character that he would he would
kind of do the voice of and we just kind
of brought them together a lot of Stefan
is John Mulaney he deserves a lot of
credit for the character I mean so much
of the language of that character is
John Mulaney I have a favorite role
they're all so different I just like
that everything's so different I hope so
you know and just continue doing that
you know there's like little moments we
have like a benchmark you know or you
felt like oh man I was so loose I'm
super bad and though that was a lot of
fun or the chance to get to do some like
skeleton twins which is so different and
then bury which is its own different
thing and it's it's just wanting to be
able to swerve like that that's that's
my biggest hope right thanks for hearing
me natter on about my career I hope you
enjoyed yourself
[Music]